comment faire un portrait de Marseille
sans les comédiens de Plus Belle La Vie
le seul feuilleton à dépasser les 1000
épisodes en France et à rassemblé entre
5 et 6 millions de téléspectateurs
chaque soir je les retrouve juste après
cet
[Musique]
extrait chaque soir 6 millions de
téléspectateurs ne rateraient pour rien
au monde leur feuilletons préféré Plus
belle la vie depuis sa création il y a 5
ans et après plus de 1000 épisodes le
succès est toujours au rendez-vous
intrigue amoureuse histoire de famille
conflit de génération drame passionnel
Plus Belle La Vie contient tous les
ingrédients du feuilleton populaire et
aborder tous les thèmes sans tabou c'est
la première série française où on voit
deux hommes s'embrasser et où deux
grand-mères tiennent des propos
stupéfiant vous êtes sûr que c'est là
mais oui c'est le coin des dealers c'est
la petite policière qui m'a donné
l'information je vous fais confiance
vous êtes dans votre élément ah pas du
tout avant machimio j'avais jamais pris
une marijuana je crois pas tourné à
Marseille le feuilleton est une
machinerie énorme 130 techniciens 10
réalisateurs 25 comédiens principaux et
des dizaines de rôles secondaires
s'active dans les studios marseillais où
ont été construits de gigantesques
décors don le fameux quartier du Mistral
où se nouent toutes les intrigues du
feuilleton papa où tu vas parler papa
c'est pas une bonne idée tu rentres à la
maison tu prends une douche et tu te
reposes qu'est-ce que vous faisiez hier
soir la raffinerie pardon l'â du
feuilleton est telle que chaque année
plus de 100000 visiteurs viennent à
Marseille pour découvrir le quartier du
Mistral mais là une surprise les attend
plus belle la vie un impact énorme les
gens viennent nous demandent le quartier
du Mistral le bar du Mistral ils sont
très très déçus quand ils apprennent que
la série est tournée en décor mais on a
même des gens qui se mettent en colère
et qui nous disent ça existe pas et
c'est dommage le baristral vraiment ils
y croient ils y croient beaucoup les
héros de Pagnol ont peut-être du souci à
se faire car ceux de Plus belle la vie
ont encore de belles années devant eux
comme le pense Michel corde un des héros
de la série et ça peut durer très
longtempsin paraî qu'il y a un
feuilleton anglais qui a duré 40 ans
dans 40 ans Jeuris plus là ça c'est
sûr comment comment comment mais bien
sûr vous serez là dans 40 ans Michel
cord et ben écoutez
fa Fabienne
peut-être alors Fabien Cara Michel corde
vous êtes l'un et l'autre on va dire
parmi hein les principaux personnages de
ce feuilleton ce succès a complètement
j'imagine aussi transformé un peu votre
votre vie vous nêtes oui marseillais ni
l'un ni l'autre
non moi je je je suis un vrai du Sud je
suis plutôt un languedossien je suis
originaire de la région de Montpeller on
vous pr pour un Marseillais je suis sûr
peut-être pas les Marseillais d'ailleurs
ah non les vieux marseillais me disent
non on sa que vous êtes pas de là mais
c'est pareil pour vous c'est pareil
parce que j'ai j'ai un vrai accentin bon
c'est le sud moi avec mon père je ne
parle pas français je ne parla que
l'occiitan oui oui je ne parlais que
l'occiitan je écrit et tout vous parlez
ocitant je le parle couramment je je
suis biling de naissance si vous voulez
voilà mon père était un auteur ocitant
assez connu donc il estimait que le
français nétait pas sa langue et nous
parlait nous ses enfants en ocitant et
comment dit plus belle la vie en ocitant
my mais il faudrait trouver un autre
titre dès que vous changez de langue
vous traduction de trahisonou et alors
est-ce que vous av ça a transformé votre
vie est-ce que vous avez déménagé
puisque je sais que beaucoup de
comédiens se sont installés à Marseille
le temps passant alors oui beaucoup se
sont installés à Marseille beaucoup
vivent à cheval entre Marseille et une
autre ville enfin moi c'est mon cas je
vis à cheval entre Marseille et nîes
c'est pas loin double vie
Michel oui en quelque sorte la vie privé
je parle de professionnel évidemment
cela cela s'entend non la vie
professionnelle
elle est elle est à Marseille le
feuilleton est trop prenant pour
vraiment faire des choses importantes
vraiment importantes à côté quoi ou
alors il faudrait partir un petit peu
est-ce que ça vous a obligé Fabienne à
faire des choix aussi sentimentaux parce
que que quand quand on quitte une ville
on peut avoir des liens dans
cette dans cette ville c'est vrai que
moi j'avais une histoire d'amour à Paris
quand la série est arrivée et quand
j'étais prise et mais c'était une fin
d'histoire et du coup ça tombait très
bien non c'est vrai et alors maintenant
que vous êtes à Marseille vous avez un
petit copain marseillais ou pas oui un
grand copain marseillais un grand copain
marseillais lu même assez costaud
connaissis tout à l'heure
alors vous allez faire finalement votre
vie à Marseille peut-être je sais pas
moi je je veux pas quitter Paris je sais
pas où sera ma vie encore c'est un grand
dilemme et moi non je je je parle de
double vie c'est c'est un petit peu ça
moi j'ai une compagne que j'aime
beaucoup avec qui je suis depuis
longtemps j'avais pas envie de la
quitter donc je je vais à Marseille et
puis après je rentre en Nim et je la
retrouve voilà donc ça s'équilibre bien
pour Mo oui ça va ça s'équilibre et puis
écoutez dans le fond dans un couple
quand de temps en temps on se sépare on
se retrouve encore mieux et ça c'est pas
plus mal on croirait entendre le patron
du bar Mistral pensez que est-ce qu' il
parle comme ça il dirait ça le patron du
bar de Mistral euh il
est Rolin est un peu un petit peu plus
un petit peu plus casagier et un peu
plus attaché moi j'aime j'aime j'aime
l'air vous aimez le personnage que vous
interprétez oui oui oui j'aime bien le
personnage il a il a certains côtés de
moi puis forcément je pense que quand
quand on joue personnage depuis plus de
5 ans vous savez à la fin les auteurs je
crois qu'ils écrivent ils écrivent pour
nous moi je moi je sens que maintenant
ils écrivent un peu pour moi ils savent
ils savent ce que je peux jouer et ce
que je jouerai moins bien dites-moi
Fabien vous vous interprétez donc une
policière jeune Burret oui tout à fait
ouis oui qui a 8 ans de moins que moi
ouais qui vient des quartiers Nord donc
c'est vrai qu'on de Marseille voilà donc
on n' pas du tout eu la même vie ni le
même passé mais vous avez des orig
magrébine pas du tout non non je suis
juste
béarnaise non non mais c'est vrai que
mon côté typé maintenant est un atout
parce que c'est vrai que c'est ce qui me
donne mes plus grands personnages le
personnage que j'avais avant c'était
aussi une Algérienne donc maintenant ça
m'ouvre des portes et c'est positif
voilà après on c'est incroyable qu'on
soit allé chercher une béarnaise non
hein pour pour pour j'étais à Paris
quand même
he le casting mais mais pour jouer je
des rôles de jeunes burrett ou jeunes
magrébin
aprèi qu'est-ce que vous disent les
d'ailleurs les gens de Marseille il y en
a beaucoup qui sont très surpris de mon
vrai prénom euh parce queils s'attendent
à ce que je m'appelle Fatima
mrien Samia mais pas Fabienne bah eux
enfin les gens des quartiers pensent que
oui que je suis leur comme eux leurs
copines que je viens aussi des quartiers
donc il se confi à vous ou pas oui il y
en a qui sortent de prison donc il me
disent qui sont que je que je les ai
aidé à passer ces étapes là il y en a
même qui m'écrivent de prison ne vous
confondent pas avec
avec le personnage on va voir tout à
l'heure si mais c'est bien si si mais ça
passe bien je veux dire il voit que je
suis flic
mais mais je suis pas un salale flic
contre eux je les défends toujours Samia
elle est toujours elle est positive ah
oui oui puis
pas VI et ça il le voit Michel qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit à vous patron de barre
parce que c'est l'endroit le bar le bar
du Mistral c'est là où on cause là où on
se parle oui vous savez les les gens
dans la rue quand il vous la Coste il
parle au personnag il parle à Roland il
parle pas à Michel corde moi c'est très
souvent je leur dit non mais je
m'appelle pas Roland je Michel ah ben
oui ou monsieur alors c'est selon ou
alors avec beaucoup de déférence
monsieur Marcy ou mais c'est toujours il
s'adresse au personnage il est
extrêmement rare que quelqu'un m'appelle
ou monsieur corde ou Michel ou dans la
rue ça donne envie de pleurer d'ailleurs
quand on nous appelle par le nom du
comédien voilà un jour j'ai j'ai
expliqué à une dame que non que je
m'appelle elle m'a écrit en me disant si
vous avez honte de de r elle avait pas
compris alors que je lui disais non mais
là vous parlez à l'acteur qui s'appelle
Michel corde il ressemble au personnage
certes mais il sur sur écrit pour vous
maintenant oui mais il n'est pas le
personnage il le représente je vous
raconter une petite anecdote un jour
dans laorde et non pas Roland nous le
précisons encore au téléspectateurs je
me fais mais littéralement engueulé par
une dame à peu près de mon âge qui me
dit maintenant ça suffit mais arrêtez ne
vous laissez pas faire vous voyez pas
qu'elle vous m par debout du nezant un
moment j'ai pas bien compris il
s'agissait de Mélanie qui est la
serveuse de Roland et effectivement
Roland adore cette sa serveuse et est
très sensible mais elle engueulait
Roland parce que Mélanie le menait par
le bout du nez de manière générale
est-ce que les gens se confient à vous
oui beaucoup parlent d'eux beaucoup
Racon vous êtes d des proches voors
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous disent de leur vie
ben moi il y en a qui me racontent
vraiment leur vie en détail vraiment
vraiment tout ce qu'ils ont fait avec
qui et autrement les petites filles
c'est beaucoup d'identification
j'aimerais être aussi belle que toi
alors que moi je vais me trouver l'aide
et que je vais admirer quelqu'un d'autre
mais je vois que ils ont tous V trouver
l'aide mais non mais je dire on a tous
nos propres complexes et non mais ça ça
réchauffe le cœur c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit à vous vous avez des gens
qui vous racontent tout puis qui moi
j'ai une dame qui m'écrit pour me
m'inviter à son mariage son papa un
cancer il est très malade sa maman est
morte d'un cancer mois avant et depuis
qu'elle est morte le le papa va tous les
jours sur la tombe le matin il lui
raconte l'épisode de la veille vous
rendez compte donc elle veut m'inviter
au mariage et je décline invitation
parce que parce que parce qu'il y a des
choses à un certain moment qu'on peut
plus assumer quoi un rôle qu'on peut
plus jouer mais vous êtes un lien
essentiel rôle important de confident
voilà voilà voilà j'ai vu j'ai vu un
jour aussi une anecdote mais c'est très
importante à un moment donné est dans
dans la série dans le dans le feilleton
donc Joanna était enceinte on traitait
le problème un peu de l'enfant
l'adolescente enceinte bon qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire hein c'est pas évident
quoi B Roland est protégé première chose
et un jour j'ai croisé une fille qui m'a
dit vous êtes mon Dieu vous êtes c'est
avec une charge émotive terrible elle
explosé en pleur et pour elle qui a qui
avait vécu quasiment la même chose au
même moment et que ses parents avaient
rejeté
elle s'était raccroché à
Roland parce que que Roland protégeit la
petite fille qui vivait la même chose
vous voyez alors donc derrière qu'est-ce
que Michel corde peut peut répondre à ça
vous face à que je que je ne peux pas
assumer ce qu'elle vit dans la vie au
moment mais que si je joue quelque chose
qui est un
secours je suis très heureux vous n'avez
pas peur l'un et l'autre d'être marqué
par le saut de Plus Belle La Vie euh
c'est une question j'imagine que vous
vous posez est-ce que ça n'exclut pas
d'autres rôles finalement c'est
l'aventure maintenant c'est l'aventure
de votre vie une chose est sûre c'est
qu' on est marqué du plus belle de la
vie quoi voil ça
c'est c'est indéniable quoi je sais que
a des il y a souvent des gens qui ont
ditent mais non on peut pas il est dans
Plus belle la vie il est trop il est
trop conoté par ce feuilleton vous avez
raté d'autres choses à cause de ça
probablement et puis on est en France si
on a l'accent du midi on peut pas jouer
le rôle de quelqu'un de sérieux et de
responsable c'est comme ça c'est c'est
c'est imbécile mais c'est comme ça il y
a y a un producteur un jour qui a dit un
casting non il est très bien mais il du
midi il peut pas jouer quelqu'un de
responsable alors je vous propose
maintenant qu'on reçoive Michel mafzoli
qui est qui est sociologue qui vient
d'écrire un livre parce que vraiment
plus belle la vie maintenant on étudie
plus belle la vie et qui fait un lien
entre l'univers impitoyable de Dallas et
plus belle la vie ça vous intéresse
j'imagine oui oui oui voilà
bonsoir bonsoir Michel mafzolie donc je
disais vous êtes sociologue professeur
d'université oui à la Sorbon et alors là
vous publiez un chapitre entier dans
dans un livre sur le phénomène
sociologique de Plus Belle La Vie qui
s'intitule d'ailleurs de Dallas à Plus
belle la vie avec quelques petites
phrases préambule ou pourquoi un modeste
feuilleton bien de chez nous nous parle
autant que les tribulations d'une lignée
de capitaliste texan nevr bien rien que
ça non je veux dire que quelque chose
marche quand ça correspond à l'esprit du
temps c'est-à-dire quand c'est en
correspondance dans le vrai sens du
terme avec ce qui est vécu ce qu'on aime
ce qu'on a envie de faire ce que l'on
vit tout simplement et là dans le fond
on a toute une série de de situations où
au travers des infidélités des
turpitudes multiples et diverses des
crimes et autres vies cotidienne bien
c'est ce que l'on vit de tous les jours
c'est intéressant de voir ceil disait
d'ailleurs
précédemment et oui oui oui et qu'est-ce
que ça nous dit qu'est-ce que ce
feuilleton à succès nous dit vraiment
sur la société française et deux la
société française c'est extraordinaire
de voir quand alors vous me dites
sociologue je sais pas si je suis
sociologue parce c'est pas intéressant
d'être quelque chose dans mon pays on
dit qu'il y a que les cornichons qu'on
met dans des bocau bon donc faut bien
vous présenter façon vous avez raison on
est facee tout n rien je suis rien ça ça
me plaît beaucoup plus je suis rien mais
je vois telle telle jeune fille de 16
ans et ma vieille mère qui a 86 ans qui
regarde plus Belle La Vie chacune à sa
manière il va y trouver là quelque chose
qui représente dans le vrai sens du
terme ce qui est leur vie voilà voilà
pourquoi ça me paraît être alors le mot
savant que je dirais une coupe
histologique un petit un petit morceau
de peau que l'on découpe et c'est le
corps en son entier qui est dit qui est
décrit je pense que Plus belle la vie
traite justement de beaucoup de
différences comme l'homosexualité
l'obésité il y a des tas de sujets la
séroposité plein de choses et toutes ces
différences là qui sont traitées au sein
de Plus Belle La Vie qui est devenu
quelque chose de familier de rassurant
de connu et du coup fait que ces
différences deviennent et ben des
différences qui font moins peur et
rendre dans le quotidien et du coup il y
a beaucoup d'acceptation qui découlent
de ça moi je suis d'accord avec vous je
pense que on était resté sur une vieille
notion ringarde du 19e la République une
et indivisible le républicanisme on
évacué les différences là c'est je le
dis en latin la res public la chose
publique et la chose publique c'est une
mosaïque où vous allez avoir l'Omo vous
allez avoir l'obèse vous allez avoir et
cetera vous allez avoir tous ces
éléments et que dans le fond dans la
mosaïque chaque partie voyez c'est ça la
personne reste ce qu'elle est et
pourtant ça cohère ça tient et je pense
que le succès il repose là-dessus sur
cette idée de mosaïque non plus encore
une fois la réduction à une valeur de
bien de machin des choses mais au
contraire ce qui notre vie une pluralité
de choses la différence vécu alors
miroir pour vous de la société française
ou miroir déformé déformant et un peu
caricatural pour faire ressortir le
trait oui exactement les deux c'est pas
dérangeant ah non je le disais pas en
critique d'ailles la caricature c'est
caricaturer ça charge le trait mais le
fait de dire que de la caricature montre
que vous avez un gros nez enfin bon ça
vous déplaît un peu mais c'est vrai pas
vous moi
aucun problème non je veux dire à la
matière puisque vous n'êtes rien vous
pouvez tout dire mich aussi donc ça non
mais ça charge le trait et de fait ce
qui est en jeu c'est bien cela
c'est-à-dire que c'est une caricature
oui quelque chose qui va dire en majeur
ce qui est vécu en mineur dans la vie
quotidienne alors le problème c'est que
je vois dans le dans dans la classe dans
la casse dans le clan intellectuel qui
est le mien je dois dire donc celui des
professeurs d'université puisque vous
êtes vous êtes bien quelque chose et
quelqu'un professeur d'université à la
Sorbonne et sociolog mal heureusement je
suis ça mais enfin bon chez ces gens-là
madame oui monsieur et bien il ils vont
en quelque sorte considérer qu'il y a là
de la sous-culture moi non moi je
considère la culture c'est avant tout
comment on s'habille comment on mange
comment on parle comment et cetera et là
on a là je dis bien un petit morceau qui
nous dit en raccourci ce qu'est le corps
social en son entier c'est en ce sens ça
me paraît intéressant vousz
pour aller dans le sens de monsieuroli
moi je sais que souvent j'ai reproché
par exemple au théâtre d'être un peu
trop intellectuel et moi je je disais
lorsque j'enseignais à mes élèves je
leur disais au théâtre on ne fait pas
des raisonnements pour expliquer quelque
chose on fait on s'adresse au trip on
s'adresse à l'émotion et c'est dans la
façon dont on s'adresse à l'émotion
qu'on peut faire passer quelque chose
moi je je voudrais quand même vous
demander quelle est la différence Michel
mafzoli entre quand même Dallas
l'univers impitoy de Dallas qui était
quand même assez il y avait du
maquavellisme c'était assez sombre et et
et plus belle la vie alors la classe
n'était pas la même c'était en effet la
la la les bourgeois Texans là c'est pas
exactement la même chose mais là c'est
quand même plus gtil on est dans quelque
chose de plus pas forcément de plus
gentil quand même vous l'avez regardé
Plus Belle La Vie comment ça mais bien
sûr alors il y a quand même quand même
deses sont dures il y a du meurtre il y
a des quantités il a l'ombre est là
présente et Dallas et Plus Belle La Vie
montre qu'il y a une part d'ombre la
part du diable moi j'ai dit et que le
diable nous constitue et qu'il faut
avoir cette humilité de reconnaître et
je pense que si ça marche pour le dire
en des termes simples c'est parce que
justement le doigt est mis là-dessus
d'All là c'était la même chose et quand
on voyait ce qui était la la poivreode
de de c'était sous Hélène qui était
totalement alcoolique et ca et bien d'
de certaine manière ça ça ça cela
rappelit comment on peut aussi être
alcoolique comment on peut aussi être
infidèle comment on peut éventuellement
être arrivé à à taper à tuer à voler et
cetera et dans le fond le vieux théâtre
aristotélicien la catarcis vous en avez
parlé cette catarcis c'était ce purger
de quelque chose qui est là en nous et
qu'il est heureux que ça puisse sortir
quand le pu sort il ne contamine pas
l'ensemble du corps social et en ce sens
pense qu'il y a même quelque chose de
thérapeutique dans B la vie voyez ça
vaut la psy les machins les choses et C
c'est dire dans le sens simple du terme
ça sort donc longue vie a Plus belle la
vie c'est cela on vous le
souhaite merci beaucoup pour ne rien
manquer sur ma chaîne Inna Mireille Duma
abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche